you don't watch college football no you
don't watch any sports no I love sports
he loves a basket not I love basketball
boxing and I'm getting into MMA a little
bit cuz it is he no I just I like the
theatrics of it now and I feel like I
feel like there's a elite athlete
entering the sport it feels Mme Mme
interesting I mean you don't think there
has been I think they've been and
they've been I don't think I'll eat this
is your category I know nothing about
this [ __ ] do you not guys
not not that not that I just had Dominic
raised on the food truck diary yeah and
he was a football player and actually
got a shot in the NFL with the Jets and
the Giants yeah
and I said he explained to people like
when they go this guy's a good athlete
winner time I George st. Pierre and
still though when they go always a good
athlete about the athletes I were in
just your locker room like it's I'm
incomparable and he's and he's fighting
he's fighting john jones yeah and I said
here for so just so people who
understand there's demonstrate being a
good fighter and being an athlete I said
if before you and John fight if you did
a combine you had a 40
yeah vertical did the agility did all
that stuff did the 20 yard - everything
yeah you would absolutely destroy John
Jones destroying musically wise yeah
right everything you'd blown out of the
water technical skills that people have
to practicing it god those are athletic
they know but not have been reliance but
I don't know every great athlete can
just walk into a combine and merderet
know this is what he's saying at my
training thing no no no no this is no
it's fat run fast jump high what are the
things it's like change of direction
explosiveness those things are just
green in you yeah you're gonna you have
to train for the jump
I agree but like John Jones vertical is
gonna be I don't know like 28 yeah if
that I know I agree but I'm just saying
those aren't grain but the way that you
see these guys when they train for the
combine it's very specific to the
combine they they're they do better
technique with the four yeah there's a
lot of technique guys are just like
organically or super athletic I think
that's what you try yeah I agree some of
those guys enter some of those guys
enter like boxing or MMA right grand
they have an advantage and even you you
said this about yourself
you an advantage at a lower level
against these guys just because you were
more athletic than them even then they
have UFC had a huge advance huge of it
and then you start going to like the top
of the table then you get experience
yeah I think and when you're dealing
with someone who's been doing something
since they're six years old like that
andy ruiz fight I can't believe that he
came and so [ __ ] heavy but like
unbelievable by the way it was whole
thing but it was like himself think
about it he was key came at 283 and he
fought the whole fight at the same pace
that's what he had to what our yet but
think about it he's been boxing six
years old doing twelve rounds is nothing
yeah no it's nothing using cruise
control the fight the entire with a
paycheck didn't wanna get knocked up
that's it so eighty three came in a
sweetie that he's impressive than me
though mumbly it's so impressive that
you can just cruise like that and just
knocked out I'm Blanc Josh close my mind
like that to my incredible I not fight
oh I wish Joshua to knock them out but
no I thought Joshua father smart fight
but don't you think that's a such a
skill Ruiz like he that's just a skill
that he's exercised Ruiz yeah that's
just a skill he's lazy man he don't know
if it's lazy as much as that's what do
you know if he's lazy it was self
sabotage he gained 15 and I heard about
this before going in let him eat fat boy
need a ten-piece you gotta come through
man that's you that is a winnable fight
for him he beat him before and it's like
your this is your one opportunity and
the only advantage you huh well what
about what about the idea that he's
setting himself up to fight again if he
won that fight he'll fight again if you
won that if you won that fight he
would've made a hundred million dollars
he I was not fighting him again now he's
off it he's it's off else now you gotta
fight journeyman no you're you're cliche
you're the Buster Douglas you're the guy
who gotta be top you [ __ ] up yeah not
butterbeans a little bit broad of an
example
broad round here know what I mean it's
blue super specific yeah with a sideshow
that was beside you what I'm saying is
you're gonna become a sideshow he's a
cliche guys yeah you guy that guy I
[ __ ] it up who do you have a fight who
would I have them fight you can rematch
Parker whose work doesn't really have a
name loser vs Ortiz but then like who's
gonna watch that know I guess Mexicans
if there's no ride with him now they're
done so if they derive from he's done
he's [ __ ] he's done and he had the
opportunity look at the frustrating
opportunity so you watch too much boxing
good I'm like grandmother in a boxing
like my dad used to cover box
for when he worked in the news business
oh really he'd been to like Ali's camp a
bunch of time like crazy [ __ ] and so I
was like a huge boxing fan growing up
and then MMA I'm starting to get into
and you watch everything yeah there was
a sport that I don't like him being dead
serious last night I watch women's
handball I watch the Olympic handball
team disciplining what do you mean it
was so much fun to watch dude I don't
get any any premiere any competition I
will watch any premier athlete do what
they do and let me tell you something
loves CrossFit I'll watch the cross for
competitions love that [ __ ] if you're a
pretty much WNBA hell no I don't want
that I said from your athlete okay women
let me know what that is no I watch the
Olympic Channel sometimes I throw it on
when I'm when I'm doing work in bed okay
and an Olympic channel has like all the
trial runs and it's fun to watch these
people have sports that I've never heard
of her I've never seen before right [ __ ]
is wild as [ __ ] it doesn't make sense to
me I'm more mesmerized by sports I know
nothing about because we don't feature
them in America right but this is tough
it's kind of like it's water polo yeah
but on without a lot and smoke each
other they can smack you in the face
it's super good listen first of all it's
not gay it's a bunch of girls who are
gay it's not guys I think some of them
it's kind of dope you dive to the air
that's water polo without one you really
saw justify this bro yeah my new
favorite no you know what it is so I'll
watch any any any athletic competition
at a high level I do what like the
Olympic Trials right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]